all right it is time to celebrate our
everyday heroes with southwest medical
let's get to know
this week's honorees rosie and taylor
congratulations
thank you they surprised you when they
got you
oh yes they did
got you good so let's taco this is one
of my favorite times of the week because
obviously
now more than ever it is so important to
honor our healthcare workers our
everyday heroes
so let's get to know you both um what is
your specialty rosie we'll start with
you
i work in radiology with southwest
medical i've been with them for 30 years
wow i work in support staff so i'm the
one that gets the cds ready deliver them
to facilities or pick them up for
comparisons for the patients so they can
get whatever procedures or exams that
they need
awesome and taylor how about you i work
at
oftencare cancer care i'm a project
coordinator for supportive services
i work with genetic counseling
palliative care
social work case management and patient
assistance
and our newly hired dietitian so that's
been fun
i've been with the company as a
contractor i was with the company for
about a year and a couple months i've
only been hired on
for about two months so this was a great
[ __ ] surprise to me
wow you must be working hard if you're
already being honored after just a few
months huh
that's awesome and let's get to know
also you know what inspired
you guys to get into medicine this is
not for everybody
but somebody's got to do it right yes
rosie let's start with you
um i did it because i love helping
people always helping the community
volunteering whatever i can do to help
anybody
taylor uh for me i had gotten my
masters of health administration at
university of cincinnati
prior and when i moved out here with my
husband we
have been here about two years when we
first moved out
my mother-in-law decided not to tell us
that she had breast cancer wow so
she allowed us to move out here from
ohio to nevada without us
knowing so it was a deep shock and she's
been in remission for about two years
now
and my way of giving back was
looking for a job that was with cancer
so
cancer care was the one for me um what
makes
a good day for you at the office rosie
knowing that patients got everything
they needed to you know follow through
with their appointments
and not have exams canceled like making
sure can keep them
right staying on top of things no matter
what yes
i would agree and taylor i work more in
the background i'm not necessarily
patient facing so my good day
is making sure that i'm an asset to my
team and helping out as many people as i
possibly can
whether that's redoing an excel
spreadsheet from beginning to end
or just making sure that they have all
the necessary tools they need to be able
to run their day effectively
thank you ladies so so much
congratulations
we salute you today and every day
thank you thank you thank you so much
for your service and hard work rosie and
taylor we will be right back here on las
vegas now